yeah I'll do my best this is relatively
new to me so it's a bit it's been a year
you may see a few more deaths and I
usually like to admit it right yeah
can't edit it now [ __ ]
Oh what company that had a lot yeah
possibly stick to videos yeah I mean hey
I mean no now you're awesome
that is no 20 bucks
[Music]
a pissed-off face take me with the
technical destiny to freon fears plus
this one oh really
yeah overpriced
[Music]
I'm Karen I definite right gotcha
hey yeah yeah I'm busy
[Music]
used to love going down bekommen
university telepath that's a good knee
bed
[Music]
[Applause]
thanks heaps a random - I can't keep an
eye on that in play obviously you've
seen me die far too many times I
honestly yeah
[Music]
[Music]
oh yeah
[Music]
oh yeah totally
carrot you cane I mean yeah thanks bro
you're all good men are I need to clear
out all this owning has filled me up yes
sir yeah you're paying me for these
compliments right
[Music]
[Music]
apparently on very loud yep
are you son-of-a-bitch
jump in is still any two of us making it
awkward to old-school pcs old-school
okay thank you what
totes totes is still post legit
totes is fine I'm an old person
[Music]
okay okay okay okay
[Music]
[Laughter]
following Joe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's over
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I change builds just to today
[Music]